We now come to a very important
concept, the concept
of independence of
random variables.
We are already familiar with the
notion of independence of
two events.
We have the mathematical
definition, and the
interpretation is that
conditional probabilities are
the same as unconditional
ones.
Intuitively, when you are told
that B occurred, this does not
change your beliefs about A,
and so the conditional
probability of A is the same
as the unconditional
probability.
We have a similar definition
of independence of a random
variable and an event A. The
mathematical definition is
that event A and the event that
X takes on a specific
value, that these two events
are independent in the
ordinary sense.
So the probability of both of
these events happening is the
product of their individual
probabilities.
But we require this to be true
for all values of little x.
Intuitively, if I tell you that
A occurred, this is not
going to change the distribution
of the random
variable x.
This is one interpretation of
what independence means in
this context.
And this has to be true for all
values of little x, that
is, when [the]
event occurs, the probabilities
of any
particular little x [are]
going to be the same as the
original unconditional
probabilities.
We also have a symmetrical
interpretation.
If I tell you the value of
X, then the conditional
probability of event A is
not going to change.
It's going to be the same as the
unconditional probability.
And again, this is going to be
the case for all values of X.
So, no matter what they tell
you about X, your beliefs
about A are not going
to change.
We can now move and define the
notion of independence of two
random variables.
The mathematical definition is
that the event that X takes on
a value little x and the event
that Y takes on a value little
y, these two events are
independent, and this is true
for all possible values of
little x and little y.
In PMF notation, this
relation here can be
written in this form.
And basically, the joint PMF
factors out as a product of
the marginal PMFs of the
two random variables.
Again, this relation has to be
true for all possible little x
and little y.
What does independence mean?
When I tell you the value of y,
and no matter what value I
tell you, your beliefs about
X will not change.
So that the conditional PMF of
X given Y is going to be the
same as the unconditional PMF of
X. And this has to be true
for any values of the arguments
of these PMFs.
There is also a symmetric
interpretation, which is that
the conditional PMF of Y given
X is going to be the same as
the unconditional PMF of Y.
We have the symmetric
interpretation because, as we
can see from this definition,
X and Y have symmetric roles.
Finally, we can define the
notion of independence of
multiple random variables
by a similar relation.
Here, the definition is for
the case of three random
variables, but you can imagine
how the definition for any
finite number of random
variables will go.
Namely, the joint PMF of all
the random variables can be
expressed as the product of the
corresponding marginal PMFs.
What is the intuitive
interpretation of
independence here?
It means that information
about some of the random
variables will not change your
beliefs, the probabilities,
about the remaining
random variables.
Any conditional probabilities
and any conditional PMFs will
be the same as the unconditional
ones.
In the real world, independence
models situations
where each of the random
variables is generated in a
decoupled manner, in a separate
probabilistic
experiment.
And these probabilistic
experiments do not interact
with each other and have no
common sources of uncertainty.